attali si le bourdonnement des abeilles
est incessant elles ont élu récemment
domicile dans les sept hectares de
jardins du château attirés par les
couverts de plantes mellifères des
tournesols et d'effacer les qui vont
être recyclés en nutriments pour le sol
quand elle fait sèche nous allons passer
avec une tondeuse fauché au mieux et à
la laisser pourrir sur place retourner
un petit peu le terrain sur cinq qui cm
est en fait alpha à porte et amateurs
organique au sol depuis 2008 plus aucun
produit chimique n'est utilisé dans les
jardins de talcy avec des intrants
naturel cette terre de petites bosses
est devenu plus légère avec cuit sable
tu compost un peu de fumier de cheval
ont fait que ça y est on a une
pertinence avoir une couleur
vraiment et puis aussi une petite odeur
une fois tannées en année que tout ce
qui est fait reporter on en à petit sans
tri et qu'on les maladies surviennent
les jardiniers grand observateur de la
nature adaptent leur mode d'intervention
en conséquence le fait que ça soit bio
c'est aussi du challenge aussi parce
qu'il faut être très réactif là cette
année du fait de l'humidité on aime
beaucoup d' attaque qui n'était pas lieu
les années précédentes il faut être très
réactif à chaque fois donc ça aussi ça
donne un intérêt supplémentaire il ya
rien de mécanique
marion va avec l'humidité les lavant qui
ont trop de mycorhizes au sol et qui
pourrissent est donc là il faut réagir
tout de suite c'est pas spécialement
même des traitements
bio on a dégagé les pieds pour les
laisser respirer et apparemment ça
marche et
le recours aux méthodes douces a profité
à la biodiversité
les oiseaux ont suivi les insectes et
des espèces sont apparus que l'on
n'avait jamais vu auparavant